[Music]
tailgate guys have you ever heard of
this business
no so this this came up at farm con so i
go to this dinner with this guy he
listens to the pod and he was telling me
i was like you know uh i was trying to
make small talk at this dinner where i
was like okay i hate normal small talk
like i'm not just gonna oh yeah how's
the conference going good yeah good how
about you good good
and i also don't know anything about
farming so like it's not relevant to me
so you know okay i can ask them a bunch
of questions you like corn too
yeah exactly you know i don't have much
to add so what's your favorite type of
corn so i was a bit of an ice breaker i
was like um
i was like first job like what's your
first first job first first first i
don't know i asked did you have a side
hustle in college
and uh i went around the table i was
like did you have a side because
everybody was doing something different
now and they're all established now but
did you when you were in college have a
side hustle and everybody had an
interesting one so this i put that in my
question bank of like ah interesting uh
you know fun little convo when you're in
a in a kind of entrepreneurial group
so one guy tells the story he goes yeah
dude i um
i think he went to like ole miss or like
what alabama or like one of these like
southern football colleges
and he's like i created a um like
tailgate in a box it's like what he's
basically like yeah like tailgating is
huge before the football game people go
to the parking lot they want to grill
and drink and play beer pong and do all
the stuff
and um he's like you know for he's like
my family used to like to do it so he's
like first my family it was so
competitive so you had to go wait like
kind of overnight to get your spot he's
like so they would send me i'd have to
go down to the i forgot what was called
the grove or something like that and i'd
have to wait in the parking lot and hold
my family spot
then i started to be like okay cool you
got the spot well like well you got to
set up the tailgate for us like come on
we need a tables for beer pong and we
need this and that so he's like okay
i'll get the stuff every week and i'll
go do it and he would create a good
setup and then the
space next to him was like hey dude
can we next week can we just will you
set ours up and he's like all right uh
give me like 200 bucks i'll get you guys
some stuff like yeah sure
and then the price goes up and he's like
oh my i can basically charge each little
tailgating square like each little group
of friends
500 to just set up a cool tailgate spot
for them turnkey tailgating and so he
did this at his college and he's like
dude i was making thousands and
thousands of dollars every semester
running this um and i was like is it i
googled tailgate guys did it get
acquired so so that was their competitor
so there was a nationwide version of
this he was doing this at small scale
that was his college side hustle just to
make a little bit of money he's like
yeah tailgate guys tried to come in
but uh they couldn't break into our
market like we owned our market and i
was like who's tailgate guys he's like
oh these guys basically took this idea
and they started doing it nationwide and
i was like that's really smart he goes
yeah but how does it work do you have
like you just hire college kids and you
say we'll give you 50 50 an hour for
three hours on saturday we get 50 you
get 50. exactly and then do they do the
kids go to like walmart and buy the
stuff i think either you give them the
supplies in bulk or um or they have to
go grab it and you tell them hey you
need to get this table and these bowls
and this beer this whatever and you use
like a company credit card exactly
something that has exactly and so
tailgate guy and what they do
the key is they would partner with the
school they would say hey we'd like to
be the exclusive tailgate provider for
the school
and the school would give them the
license and so they had a monopoly and i
was like what
and it's like yeah actually this is
pretty common that schools will
basically pick one
vendor provider they'll sell the license
rights basically they'll let you become
the official you know north carolina you
know
you know the tar heels
you call it tar heel tailgate and it's
like their thing and you pay them a fee
or a revenue share of what's going on
but in exchange you get a monopoly you
get to be the only provider of this
and it's like super viral right because
you're just like
everybody sees wow that setup looks not
bootleg what is that oh they use
tailgate guys or whatever okay cool we
should use them next time
and uh so tailgate guys apparently like
i think they got bought out by private
equity or something but they um
they were doing like i don't know
30 to 50 million dollars a year doing
this what and um and i thought what a
great
example of a college hustle that you
then scale up you say all right if this
works at my college it's going to work
at every college and every college that
has a football program that has
tailgating and then we have this
repeatable sales model of going to the
university and we tell them hey these
other eight universities partnered with
us
we'd like to partner with you you get
extra income and we will provide a safe
uh you know convenient way for your your
fans to do this i thought that's pretty
this is a really cool little niche
business and then i started thinking
well what are the other ones what are
the other businesses that use the same
sales tactic of basically
partnering with the school and becoming
the exclusive provider so we had a
little mini brain mini because the guy
listens to the podcast so we had like a
mini brainstorm session at dinner where
he's like dude this is happening also
with scooters uh when like bird and lime
came out in cities
companies decided oh shoot we should
become the exclusive scooter provider on
campus like we'll go
drop these scooters all everywhere it'll
be branded by this with the school the
school will get a rev share for every
scooter ride that happens and we get a
captive market that nobody can compete
with us in and so this started happening
with scooters and i was like oh damn
what else could be done because scooters
is cool because it's a new category
right tailgating worked because it was a
new category so you just have to think
about like what's something today that
they don't even really have a um
like an option for like they're not
really there isn't really like a market
for it
[Music]
you